遅くなります まだ始まりますけど
よろしくお願いします
今日はあの おそらく二百六十三ページから始めています
またあの繰り返しては言ってしまうと
まあ時間がなくなりますから
あのまあ今日止まったところから
けど まあ一応アビダンマの最後のところで
えっと ヴィパッサナー瞑想において心はどういう風な段階で段階で成長できるかっていう
ことなんです まあ一応いくらかは全部説明いたしましたけど
で あの 私の説明はあまり理解できないと思うならば
大変明確にあのあの清浄道論ですか
で そちらに全部詳しく書いてますから
そこ日本語訳もありますから
ああいうのになったら私が間違ったところとか
まあ忘れたところもあるし
で そこら辺読めばよろしいと思います
まあこちらアビダンマテキストを追って
ただあの基本的な言葉だけの説明なんですね
まあそれだけで終了したいと思います
で それからあの まああの瞑想のテキストとかね
いろいろございますので
あのミャンマーの瞑想法というテキストにも
そこら辺にヴィパッサナーのヴィスッディのことを書いているし
そういう専門家の方々が書いたテキストを読むとわかると思います
で あまりの実践的なところだからね
私にとってはなかなか言いにくいところたくさんありますので
それから瞑想 ヴィパッサナー瞑想の経験済みの方々にもいろいろ相談してみると
そういうことか そういうことかと
まあ理解できるかなと思います
私にできるのはそういう深いところではなく
ただ言葉の説明だけですから
そこだけにします まあ 1番目はこのシーラ・ヴィスッディということで
あのヴィスッディという言葉には
この清らかになるということで
あの 清らかになるっていうことは順番に清らかにならなくてはならないんです
まあ大体 2週間ぐらい
3週間ぐらい あの厳密に瞑想なさると
まあかなりのところまで心は透けてます
あの あまりにも地かにしがみついて
もう自分の心を絶対もう先生たちには言わないと状況を暴れないようにというふうに
このすごい頑固で頑張る方々は永久的に同じところにいますけど
まあそうじゃなくて  プライドも置いといてね
まあただ単に修行瞑想すれば
まあそういうステージには自動的に行けるんです
で  今のうちは私には誰も何も言ってくれませんだからから何もわかりませんだけど
まあそれは信頼していないということになりますけど
あの まあ一人の方は知ってますけど
あの それから特色として言えば
もう勉強もできない で
みんなにもう頭が悪いと捨てられていて
で 本人もそうだと思っていて
そこでまあ正直にしゃべったことも瞑想だけやっていて
まあそれでもちゃんと
まあこれから説明するように
順番にね あの 私も何も言ってないんだからね
まあ成長してはいけるんです
だからこの時間の関係がありまして
この最終的なところにはなかなか行けないんですね
だからこの心統一して
このすごいエネルギーを固まって減らす心っていうのは
まあ時空的なあるものだから
それのまあ変速して この人によりますから
力絞ってもらわないとね
まあそういう時間の関係で
全く無意味なことで もう一つ残っているということになっているんですけど
で そういうことで この段階的には 1番目はシーラ・ヴィスッディ
それは説明いたしましたし
まあシーラっていうのは道徳のことで
人間は何やるにしたっても
最初から道徳的な立派な人間にならないと何もできません
ですから  それで道徳で我々は何をコントロールするかというと
この怒りと欲という 2つがありまして
私たちは怒りと欲でいつでも行動しているんですね
で まあそれあの世の中はそうは認めません
世の中は大変 このみんな人間必死に立派に頑張っているんではないかというふうに言っているんだけど
仏教は大体人間の行動っていうのは欲と怒りに基づいてやっているものですよと
ですから それほど道徳的ということは
この心理の心理っていうのは心の法則の立場からは言いにくいと
ですから この人が何かいいことをしたんだからといって
それは道徳的な行為というふうにいきなり結論を出すことはできません
だから結果から見るか
例えばいやしたいいことはいい結果になったならば
まあしょうがないんですね
結果は良ければ その場合はその人の行為はいいことですよと
で 結果を見て恰好の行為を判断できます
まあいい行為でしたと
なぜならば結果は良くなったんだから
それは一つの判断方法
もう一つの判断方法っていうのは気持ち
目的は何ですかと だから本当に怒りと欲でないあの布団とふちの衝動でやる行動はすべて善行為になります
で 結果は別にあの別に気にしなくてもいいんです
でも なぜならば いつでも希望通りな結果になるというわけじゃないんだから
でも あの普通布団縁でやる行動はどう見たって悪い結果は出しません
たとえ人がいくら下手であろうとも
結果は悪くはならないんです
なぜならば そこにあるのはむさぼりではないんですね
布団の気持ちだから 物は自分のものにしようとかね
そういう気持ちは全くないんですね
自我を出してやろうとか
ですから 結果はもう必ずしもいい結果になる
怒りがない場合は そちらにあるのは生命愛する気持ちだから
悪い結果にはなるはずがないんです
でも 欲望を持ってる人間がもっといい結果が望んでいたんですよと
なんだこんなこれぐらいの結果ですよと
欲望の塊の人々はもう言うかもしれません
それに引かれてしまって
やっぱり結果があまり良くないんだとというふうに本人が考える可能性もあります
でも それは全く関係ない話で
理論的な話で 本人の気持ちが不貪不瞋不痴であるならば
行為の結果はいつでもよろしい結果なんです
それはもう決まってるんです
それで道徳の世界っていうのは
人間にはやっぱりいつでも貪瞋痴がありますから
この貪瞋痴の衝動で行動するなということなんですね
喋る時は貪瞋痴で喋ってはいけませんし
行動する時は貪瞋痴で行動してはいけませんと
で それだけで全ての戒律の世界が成立してしまうんですね
喋る時も行動する時も
心の衝動は何ですかと言えば
それは不貪不瞋不痴でなければなりませんと
もし貪瞋痴で行動したならば
それは全部道徳を犯したことになります
大体そのように徹底的に自分が決めて
優しい心でいつでも喋りますと
優しい心で行動しますと
いつでも欲だけでは行動しませんよということは決めることができれば
これ大変な人格の展開なんです
生き方はものすごく変わるはずなんです
これ 楽になるか苦しくなるかって置いといて
もう人間としての生き方は全く普通の人間とはまるっきり違う道に行ったことになるんですね
人間というのは貪瞋痴で生きていて
貪瞋痴を正当化することを増やすことだけ考えているんですね
人間の社会も動物の社会も
ですから じゃあ私は不貪不瞋不痴でいきますよと決めたとこだけでも
その人は世俗の俗世間行く道とは全く度違う道に行くことに決めたことになります
だから結構きついかもしれませんだけど
それだけでもう心は清らかな方向に行ってしまったと
方向を向いたんですね
いわゆるまっすぐ歩いてるんだけど
ぎゅっとこの方向は変えてしまったんだから
同じ歩き方なんですけど
違う方向へ方向を変えましたからね
歩いてしまいちゃうんですね
だからヴィパッサナーの世界で悟りの世界で一番目にやらなくてはならないのはそれなんです
それガタガタといい加減だったら
もうカッコつけて瞑想だけやってもそんなにうまくいくという証拠はないんです
人間にとっては このシーラの戒律の道さえももう大変なことなんです
それほど簡単ではないんです
なんかこれ命に関わる問題のように感じるんですね
そういうことをしたら
もしかすると生きていられないんではないか
ただ 生きていられないんではないかと思うこと自体に生きることを正当化しているんだから
その人は無理です それだったらもう弱肉強食の世でもう生きていなさいと
こちらに来るなということを言わなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから こちらもうこの七つの清浄の段階では
こういう人間の腐ってる文句なんかは効かないんです
すごい厳密なんです そうでないと本物にはならないんですね
ですから 今まで説明した戒律とは随分訳が違うんです
この浄土段階の戒律っていうのは
で そこであの度道が変わえるんだけど
本人の心にそれだけのことで貪瞋痴が消えたんですかというと
もう消えたわけじゃない
貪瞋痴はあるんだけど
貪瞋痴を正当化する増やす道ではいけませんと
不貪不瞋不痴の方に行くんだということだから
だから この心の中で繊細的に自分を貪瞋痴に引かれているし
引っ張られているし 自分の意識のところで
良心のところで もう不貪不瞋不痴の方へ努力しようという大変な闘いになるんですね
だから中途半端ではできないんですね
だから戒律の世界はもうそれは大変難しいんです
初めは で だから長い間仏教を理解して納得して
普通の戒律を守って もうよくよくよく研究してね
心の状況をね いくらか諦めになってね
こんなもう中途半端ではもう何もできませんと覚悟を決めて
もう戒律を守るぞというふうに
自分本人の良心か覚悟っていうものは変えれない限りはね
難しい それから今説明したのは
この戒律って何ですかと説明する場合は
貪瞋痴に基づいてやってる言葉の行為と体の行為をやめることは戒律なんです
怒りと欲が増える行動をやめること
あるいは怒りと欲では行動しませんと
欲と怒りでは行動しませんということは戒律なんです
人と話す場合は 私は今欲で喋っているか
怒りで喋っているかと気をつけないか
気をつけないと あの言葉は全部不善なんです
だから悪い言葉を言ってることになっちゃうんです
だから必ずもその場合は嘘も言っては無駄話もするわ
例えば怒りで喋ってて
人のことを憎んで喋っていると
事実だけ喋りましょうということにならないで
まあいい加減にあのことをずっと喋るようになっちゃいますから
無駄話もするわ 嘘も言うわ
噂も言ってしまっちゃう
で それからもう悪口も言うようになってしまっちゃう
で 体の行動に使っても同じことで
で そういう戒律の世界で
このまた項目戒律というものがありまして
項目戒律はまああの まあ減ったり増えたりいろいろありますけど
まあ項目戒律っていうのは
この理解できない人に
この真実のレベル 真実の真実ではなくて
この心のレベルで 心の働きのレベルで理解できない人には
やっぱりこれしてはいけない
これしてはいけない これしてはいけないと項目を言わなくちゃいけないんですね
で 項目だけ覚えて守ることは大変難しい
項目を忘れてしまう でも知恵のない人にとっては
それはやりやすいかもしれません
例えばこちらは立ち入り禁止と看板書いておくと
そこを見たらここは入ってはいけませんと入らないようになります
例えば嘘言わない 嘘言わないということは一つの項目なんですね
それで じゃあ嘘言わないんだと
で 本人がその戒律を守ろうとする
でも完璧には守れないんですね
なぜかというと忘れる
忘れたところで嘘を言って
性あります もう一つは嘘って何ですかと
そこは理解しているんですか？だからこの嘘言わないという戒律を守る本人が
自分が嘘って何ですかと
自分が理解している定義に基づいて嘘を言わないようにするんです
じゃあそれでいいんですかと
人の個人的な勝手な解釈で私は嘘言わないとかね
言って嘘っていうのは
私はこういう風な意味でとってます
もう一人だと いや私はこういう風な意味でとってますよと
思ってるんだから そこはもう
ちょっと疑問なんですね
そういうことで嘘言ってはいけないというところで
嘘の定義もしなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
殺生してはいけませんと言ったところで
殺生って何ですかと 生命って何ですかと
殺生の行為はどういうものかともきめ細かく定義していかないと
人間の行動はバラバラになっちゃうんです
例えば 殺生してはいけないということは
あのキリスト教でも言ってますね
でもそちらでは生命の定義
自分勝手な定義がありまして
キリスト教独特の定義がありまして
イスラム教についてはイスラム教独特の定義があります
生命の定義 それによって殺生しないということにはなってますけど
事実上は どうもやり方いろいろ違うんですね
例えば仏教の人は殺生しないということと
キリスト教の人も殺生しないと言ったら
じゃあ二人とも仲がいいんだから同じことだから仲良くやりましょうと思っても
仲良くできないところがあるんですね
そこら辺はいろいろ違うところ見えてきます
例えば 同じ神を信仰しているユダヤ人もイスラム人もキリスト教の人々も
ものすごい互いに仲が悪いんです
ものすごく仲が悪いんです
社会的にはユダヤの人方々はこのキリスト教の人々と一緒に行動していますけど
宗教になっちゃうと明確にもう出ていて
ということでもものすごい激しい
だからこの同じ神だから
イスラム教の人もキリスト教の人もユダヤの人も
もう仲良くすれば同じじゃないかと
そう同じにならないってそういうわけなんで
まあこの定義のことで神を定義する場合は
イスラム教の定義とキリスト教の定義とユダヤの定義はそれぞれ違う
創りを定義するとまたそれぞれ違う
で 生命は何でしょうか？定義するとまたそれぞれ違うんですね
だから実際に大事なのは
我々はどのように生きているかということ
頭の中で神の名前はジェホワかアッラーかどっちか
そこはどうでもいいことで
アッラーの代わりに他の名前を入れたってもね
田中さんと入れた神の名前は田中ですよと言ったって
それどうったことないんだけど
だから実際の問題は 我々がどのように人間の社会で生きているかということで
人間の問題だから そこら辺でうまく平和的に仲良くできなくなっているのは
こうやってこの戒律の世界から生まれてくる問題なんですね
だから項目を作っても
そちらには問題が出てくるんです
嘘言わないという項目を世界人類はみんな守っても
なかなか仲良くならないんですね
それでもって またお互いに喧嘩するように
戦争を起こすようになってしまっちゃうんですね
なんでその矛盾あるかと
嘘言わないんだから みんな嘘言わない人々だから正直でしょうと
だから信頼できるでしょうと
ということはなぜできないんですかね
みんな嘘を言わないということは
信頼できる人間ということなんです
互いに信じる 信じていればもう何も問題ないでしょうに
まあ近い 近いところの例を出しちゃう
例えば北朝鮮と韓国が仲良くしたいという気持ちが韓国の方にあるみたいですね
最近は で それでいろいろ問題があるんだと
もし北朝鮮の方が我々は原子爆弾なんか作ってませんと作りませんと言ったら
あ そうですか それはありがとうよかったという風にはなぜ信頼しないかと
じゃあ私たちもあなた方を攻撃することをやめますと
コツコツとどんどんどんどん関係持って仲良くしましょうというふうにはなれないんですね
だから なぜならないかというと
じゃあ北朝鮮は認めますかね
私たちは嘘つきやと認めません
いつでも否定するでしょうね
とんでもないんだと そんなことは我々はしてないんだと
だから 国として国は嘘つきな国だっていうことはもう認めませんだけど
だから本人たちは本当のことを言ってるつもりですけど
やっぱり認められませんね
本当に本当のことを言ってる
だから堂々とはっきり言えば堂々と嘘を言ってるかもしれませんね
だから堂々と嘘を言ってるのは
その連中の その人々の定義から見れば
まあそれは正しいと それぐらいのことは
北朝鮮はものすごい力強くなければいけませんと
隣の国に対してもう大変危険な存在でないと
我々の偉大さをね 金日成の偉大さはわかってくれないとは思っているかもしれません
だからそこはもう第三者から見れば
もう何というバカなことですかと
というふうに思うかもしれません
本人はそう思わない ですから
この嘘言わないということ自体にしても
世の中はそうやっていろんなケースに立っても
なかなか何だろうかと
これは じゃあそれで北朝鮮は嘘を言う
まあ悪い国やと 日本が文句を言うでしょうし
じゃあ日本の政府は日本の国は嘘をついて言わない
皆様機嫌悪くなるんだから私は例を出したくないんだけど
いくらでも出せるんです
リストアップしてでも
何か言ったらそれは嘘
何か発表したらそれは嘘なんです
まあ違う立場で見ると
じゃあだからといって日本の国民も日本の国家も政府も我々は嘘つきの国やと認めないんですから
認めたくないんです じゃあ日本を置いておきましょう
じゃあ世界の一番大きい一番力強い国
アメリカは全然正義の味方だから嘘言わない
そこで冗談でもいいんだから
アメリカは嘘つきだと言ってみてください
どうなるかと 基本的には嘘は言わないということをみんな認めていて
実行になると これまたすごいバラバラなんですね
だからそれでは何の意味もないんですね
何の結果もないんです
だから嘘を行ったって言わなくたっても
どうでもいいことになっちゃうんです
だからそういう中途半端な
もう生ぬるい生き方と仏教の解脱の道とは全く関係ない
嘘 油です だから出世間の世界
この七つの段階で我々生きているのは
嘘を言わないということは
厳密に嘘を言わないっていうことなんです
まあそうやってこのただ嘘という一つの項目を私は取り上げただけ
まだたくさん項目があります
まあ皆様わかるのはただそれぐらいですからね
殺生と嘘というぐらいでしょうにね
もっといっぱい項目ありますけど
殺生しないと思っても
いや 我々は殺生しませんけど
みんな言うんです 誰も認めない
私は殺戮者ですよと 私は殺すのが好きで好きでたまらないんだと言う人はいませんね
ということは みんな殺生は嫌いです
じゃあそれで世の中に生命殺されることはなくなっているんですかね
全然全くもう関係なく
みんな生命を殺さないように言ってはいるんだけど
昔から今までもこれからも社会には何の変化もなく
もう同じレベルで殺したり殺されたりしていくことはもう終わらないんですね
ですから そこら辺でまあおかしいことに
戦争に行って人を殺す人さえも
自分たちが殺戮者だと認めないんです
あれはもう殺人にはなりませんと
敵ですから 敵軍を倒すべきですよ
敵 敵の国だからね それはもう倒すべきですよ
テロ活動やってる人々でも
で 自分が誰に対して反対しているかっていうのをテロたちはわかってないんですね
ただ 誰かでも誰でもいいんだから殺せばいいと
そうすると正しい自分の意見は通用すると
大変苦しんでいる あの
何て言いますか 搾取されている自分たちのの正義はもうそれで認めてくれるといって
平気でホテルを爆破するわ
飛行機を爆破するわ それでソニアガンディさんもまた暗殺するような計画
この LTTE というタミル人のテロたちがもう計画されてくるっていうことは
昨日インターネットで読みましたけど
ずっと計画はこういう風に
こういう風になって まあ一応アフリカで計画を組んで
アメリカの誰か誰か誰かにあのいろんなことをやってる人々に頼んで
そちらにお金払って あの
実行してほしいと だからインドのどこら辺
どこら辺でこれ実行するかっていうところまでありまして
まあそれからまだこの LTTE というこのタミル人の虎の限りはのこのリーダーがあのスリランカにいるんだからね
あの その人はまだあの最終決断は出してないんだと
で 活動は南アメリカでやってるんです
南アフリカで それで自分たちがあのソニアガンディさんというあのインドの前の首相の奥さんであるし
で まあガンディさんもラジブガンディさんの殺したしね
暗殺すると同じテロたちに
だから理由は このラジブガンディさん暗殺したこのグループをみんな死刑になったんです
みんな捕まってはないんだけど
捕まった人々もまあ一応裁判で有罪になって
それから最高裁判では戦いますと言って世界中からお金を集めたんです
テロたちが で それもインターネットを通してお金を集めてきたんですかね
で 集めて でもまたそれ却下されて
もう有罪になったんですね
それは正しくないんだと
その恨みを通して じゃあ奥さん殺しますと
そういう理屈なんですね
ですから このだからといってタミル人が自分たちが殺人者だって認めたのかいと聞いたら全然認めてません
我々こそ正しいんだと
という風には言ってるんですね
まあそのようにこの世の中でみんな立派な善人たちなんですけど
誰一人も嘘を言わない
誰一人も人は生命は殺しません
誰一人ももう人を誹謗したり
批判 非難したりしないんです
みんなすごい行儀よく
文化的な立派な人間なんですけど
聞いてみれば でも世界は 1時間でも平和になることはないんです
我々のは一本でも落ち着いていることはできないんです
だからそういうこのもう何の意味もない矛盾だらけの道徳
矛盾だらけの文化 矛盾だらけのこの
先帝の と持って悟りという
じゃあまた悟りたいんだと
言葉を聞くとき 私は吐き気がするんです
悟りたいんだから教えてくれと
だからもうすごくやる気が元気だったんだから
この顔を見せなかったんだけどね
もう年取ってもボロボロになって
もう元気じゃないんだよ
私も精神的にも肉体的にも
だからそのまんまで言うんです
コントロールしないで
だから それは今すごく気持ちいいんです
私はパチンコでも行っていっぱいもう玉を出したいんだけど
何か悪い工夫でもないんですか？と言ったら
そうですねと考えてあげることさえもできますけどね
気持ちいいんです 正直だから
で まあだからこの そういう大変な世界なんです
そんなこの完全たる偽善な道徳で完全たる偽善なこの
インテリ的でも文化的な人間で
また悟りもそのプラスアルファでと
そういう悟りは世の中にないんです
それはもう我々はこそ正義の味方ですよというために
世の中でみんなやっていることと同じだから
これはもう一つの偽善にしか何もないんですね
ですから このアブダルの世界と言ったっても
仏教の世界では そこすごく人間の生き方だから
それをよくわかっていて
まず戒律の段階 ということで
で そこはまあ結構厳しいと
厳しいということは 別にこの肉体的な厳しさではないので
これはちょっとした精神的な問題で覚悟を決めるか決めないか
貪瞋痴の泥の沼に溺れているか立ち上がるかと
覚悟をしなさいと 私も私も綺麗になりたい
私も綺麗になりたいって汚物ばっかり入ってる泥の沼で泳いでいるんだと
でもこれも気持ちいいんだと
でも綺麗にもなりたいんだと
それ 2つなり方ないんですね
ですから 本当の悟りの世界というかね
本物の場合は 最初のもうきちんと覚悟を決めてほしいと
ですから 戒律には一応 2つの立場で
一つはこの 理論というかね
戒律をきちんと定義して
理論的にわかりやすく貪瞋痴で行動しないこと
ただそれだけ 貪瞋痴を正当化するように
増えるように身口 体と心だけ
考え方はそれ入ってないんです
考え方はこれから瞑想で直しますからね
喋る言葉と自分を行う行動
そこは貪瞋痴のためにはやらないと
それで完璧に戒律なんです
その定義だけで でもそれでわからないというならば
まあまず五戒ありますね
殺生しないと盗もをしないと
よこしまな行為をしないと
嘘を言わないと 麻薬を使わないと
酒麻薬を使わないと五戒やります
五戒守るだけで自分がなんとなく心は
なんて言いますか 清らかになるように感じないとなれば
もう八戒やります 八戒守ったっても
なんか自分では気持ちしっかりしないと思うならば
十戒やります それでももっとしっかり戒律守るだけならば
出家の十戒やります 出家の十戒はまあ五十になります
五十八ぐらいになりますけど
同じ十戒ですけど ちょっと増えるんです
で 自分が戒律いくつか付くんです
で それは戒律とは言ってないんだけど
出家したら沙弥出家したら
あのブッダに対して批判したら出家は終わり
法を何か批判したら終わりと
サンガを批判したら終わっちゃうんです
それから先生やらね 指導者を批判しちゃったら
まああんたもう出家ではありませんと変える
それから仏教で教えてる真理以外のこと考えたりしたら
もうはい どうぞ出ていってくださいということで
一つついちゃうんです
それはもう一般の在家の方々にはなかなか知られない
たまたま遊びに あの格好つけるためにどこか行って出家して衣を着たっても
その知られません それはかなりきついんです
で 目上の出家のお坊さんに対してはすごいもう厳密に言う通りにやらなくちゃいけない
それで喧嘩してはいけない
まあ沙弥だからガキだからね
まあどうせもう喧嘩するでしょうし
それはダメなんです で
喧嘩してはいけないということは
やっぱりまあ長老たちがどうせ大人の男たちだから
まあまあ子供のことだからそれなりに判断しますから
その場合は長老の判断に従わなくちゃいけない
いい加減にしなさいと言っただけだったら
まあいい加減にすればいいんです
あるいはあんた その喧嘩したことは悪いんですよとと言ったら
もうだってこういうことよ
それはダメです 長老が悪いと言ったら悪いんで終わっちゃうんです
だからそうやって まあ沙弥の沙弥の時代っていうのはもう大変な時代なんです
ものすごい難しいんです
だからまあ言葉遣い方
それすごい厳しいんです
いい加減にこの目上の人々に言葉はもう自分勝手に使ったりしちゃう
それはもうまず直してくる
そういう言葉を使わないと
こういうこういう言葉で上の坊さんたちを呼びますよ
それでも言っちゃったら
まあまあクビ飛んじゃうんです
それでいろいろ罰もあります
十種類に罰ありまして
普通は体罰はありまして
体罰といったってもこれもう徹底的に恥かせる罰なんです
ただ ぶん殴るとか それは仏教ではないんです
その代わりに労働させちゃうんですね
何かを 何かの労働をさせますけど
その労働もちゃんと罰を与えていることをみんなに知らせるようにしなくちゃいけない
これは自分がこの今罰を受けているんだ
で ただお寺のお仕事している格好で
私はお寺のことを助け助け手伝っているんだということはダメです
私はこうやって罰を与えられて
この罰をやってるんだということを言わなくちゃいけない
それから まあ一応寺から追い出すという項目があります
寺から追い出す で まあ一番厳しい罰っていうのは
まあ出家から追い出すっていうこと
寺から追い出しちゃったら
他のお寺でお世話になっても構いません
他の先生のところでお世話になって
そちらでいろいろ教えてもらって
まあ自分が自分の過ちを悔い改めるならば
また元のところに戻られますけど
でも 他のところにお世話になったんだからって
その先生お坊さんは先生になりません
だからうまく逃げたっていうことになりません
先生がついてないと自分の